Kylie Jenner lands her own keeping up  spinoff  [Music]  fans will get to keep up with Kylie even  more as the reality star gives fans a  glimpse into her world on her new series  life of Kylie I feel like I'm getting  into so many cool beauty things I'm  excited about it coming this summer  fans will follow the lift kick creator  as she shares her life as a  businesswoman style icon and fashion  designer as well as hanging with her  close pals including besties Jourdan  woods every day it's something new 19  year old Kylie said in a statement quote  this show will allow me to give them a  peek inside all of the exciting things I  am working on